I don't wear socks shoes are the
toughest by far it has to be able to get
me into a nice establishment I have to
be able to work out in it it has to be
able to get wet cuz I don't want to have
like a different shoe when I'm traveling
that gets wet my feet Can't Sweat in it
and they can't smell over time yeah
that's hard would you be able to get
into a nice establishment in those
trainers do you think yeah the only
thing I've ever seen at the nicest
places is no sandals you heard of the
red sneaker effect right what there was
a study done at a conference with
businessmen they tried to quantify the
objective metrics of how smart somebody
dressed and there was an inverse
correlation between smartness of dress
and the net worth or the job title that
this person had so it's the people who
had dressed down the most that had the
most wealth checks out